25 you're the annual San Gennaro Feast
it is back the 43rd annual event begins
tomorrow at the M Resort hopefully you
saved your appetite music games rides
and of course all the Italian food you
can stand admission just 15 that was so
much pepperoni Sicilian pizza there no
that was so much bread with a little
just a dash sauce cheese and pepperoni
just enough
I'm stalling because I wanted to see the
rest of the food I know I know some
scampi there I think that looks good
they always do the funnel cakes even
though I can know this probably really
Italian but anywhere I can get a funnel
cake here's what you do you get your
funnel cake you put some marinara sauce
on it
oh don't try to impress us with a lot of
fun
whipped cream chocolate I'm good Terry
and then you go ride the rides in the
carnival section right
but anyways